ladies and gentlemen I'd like to declare
the result for the Rochester and strewed
constituency I Neil Davis being the
acting returning officer for the
constituency hereby give notice that the
number of votes given for each candidate
is as follows
Prue Bray Liberal Democrat one two five
one Daniel John Terrence burn trade
unionist
and socialist coalition - OH - Clive
Bryn Malcolm Gregory Green Party one
five one six new Shaba Parveen corn
Labour Party 10,000 three nine six mark
John reckless UK Independence Party you
Kip sixteen thousand zero zero nine and
Kelly Jane Tolhurst the Conservative
Party candidate 23,000
and 42 that that was 23,000 142 and
declare that Cali Jane Tolhurst has been
elected as the Member of Parliament for
the consistency of Rochester and strewed
I would like to thank the people of
Rochester and strewed who today have
come out in force to have their say on
the future of their area and their
country I'd like to thank the police the
returning officer Midway counts and all
the staff in Rochester and strewed and
across Midway that have been involved
with making sure these elections have
passed smoothly I would also like to
thank my fellow candidates particularly
the Nash our pecan crew Bray and Clyde
Gregory who have run lovely campaigns
and it's been a pleasure to be alongside
with them I feel extremely honored to be
standing here and want to thank
everybody who voted conservative today I
would also like to give a big thanks to
my agent Andrew Magnus my local
Association and all the volunteers have
helped me and my campaign over these
last seven months the right result has
been delivered this morning I was born
and bred in this constituency and care
passionately about the place I have
lived all my life and about the people
that I have grown up with by electing me
as your MP you have elected someone who
will fight for this area
and the people to deliver what is needed
I will work tirelessly in Rochester West
so Rochester's Drew's force of habit to
make Medway an even better place than it
is at the moment we ran a strong and
positive campaign in Rochester Astrud
focused on the economy because the
economy comes first making the country
be able to move forward with stability
we've made positive commitments to the
British people in this election
providing 30 hours a week free childcare
for working parents three to four year
olds introducing a tax-free minimum wage
cutting taxes for 30 million people by
raising the personal allowance creating
2 million more jobs
continuing with the Conservative Party's
record that we have delivered in the
last Parliament we have a strong leader
in David Cameron and we have fought on
local issues here I have fought around
Midway Hospital development in the right
place safer streets more jobs and more
infrastructure for Rochester's Drewes
and better education I promise I will
represent you and the people of all of
Rochester's strewed with integrity to
make the lives of the people that are
living here better thank you
Nate